let's talk about the seven healthiest
foods you can eat now the question is
what makes a food
healthy but to figure that out we must
also look at what foods make us
sick and of all the things that can make
us sick
as you might know already insulin is at
the top of the list so any foods that
raise insulin
because your blood sugars are now raised
would not only inhibit your health but
it's going to make you ill
also foods that deplete you of nutrients
will make you ill as well so we want
nutrient dense foods we want foods that
enhance nutrient absorption it means
low carb as one of the factors now the
two foods that don't trigger insulin
don't create an insulin response would
be fiber
and fat okay
and as far as protein goes the leaner
the protein the higher the insulin
response
in other words on the insulin index
whey protein and very low fat lean
protein really creates an insulin spike
compared to
fattier protein so we really want a
higher fat lower protein ratio in foods
if possible and then nutrient dense not
only do we want vitamins and minerals
and
trace minerals
and essential fatty acids like omega-3
fatty acids but we also would like
phytonutrients because the
phytonutrients give us additional health
benefits that go way beyond just the
regular vitamins and minerals so the
first food on our list is
sauerkraut okay now what makes
sauerkraut so down healthy well in one
cup of sauerkraut you have only six
grams of carbs with 4.1 grams of fiber
giving you a net carb of 1.9 grams so
it's just under 2 grams of carbs for an
entire cup that's incredible so that
definitely fits the definition of low
carb high fiber
and high nutrient because sauerkraut has
the highest vitamin c
of any food out there
in fact in one cup of sauerkraut there's
over 700 milligrams of vitamin c and the
daily requirements that we need are only
roughly around 75
milligrams and one cup of sauerkraut
gives us
milligrams so vitamin c is very very
important in collagen in building bone
and protecting the heart against free
radical damage it's a very powerful
antioxidant and without vitamin c you
get tired like in scurvy your joints
fall apart
you can't build connective tissues and
so your skin becomes more wrinkled and
you look older and the thing about
sauerkraut it's a really good pre and
probiotic so it's great fiber to feed
the microbes and it's fermented so it
has a lot of friendly bacteria the type
of bacteria that can actually enhance
your own bacteria because if we compare
that to yogurt which has probiotics
those friendly bacteria and yogurt get
destroyed at the stomach level whereas
the probiotic and sauerkraut
survives and it gets into the large
intestine and the other cool thing about
sauerkraut is the vegetable is cabbage
and that's one of the cruciferous
vegetables and cruciferous out of all
the different vegetables have the
highest most potent and powerful
phytonutrients
of all the vegetables that you can
possibly eat the unique thing about
sauerkraut and cabbage is that it's very
easy to digest and if you have digestive
problems
cabbage is probably going to be the best
vegetable to digest it does not produce
a lot of gas like other vegetables like
broccoli it will spike something called
acetylcholine which will help you have
regular bowel movements and increase
digestive juices and support your brain
and cognitive function
sauerkraut is very high in lactic acid
which is
beneficial to your good bacteria and not
very beneficial to the bad bacteria
pathogens
so pathogens cannot exist when there's
too much lactic acid also sauerkraut is
a really good source of vitamin k2
k2 is made by bacteria and vitamin k2
which is also in certain fats
helps to keep the calcium out of the
joint and out of the arteries and in the
bone and lastly sauerkraut is very high
in vitamin e
now you're probably going like what is
vitamin u
i put a link down below for more
information on vitamin u but it actually
is a vitamin and it has some really cool
effects on things like colitis
inflammation of the colon
great effects of ulcers
it's really good on gastritis and acid
reflux
and dirt and even gut inflammation all
right number two
arugula
now if you've been watching my videos i
recommend a good amount of salad every
single day and if you're going to eat
salad might as well use a green or a
base of salad that has higher amounts of
nutrients and arugula fits that to a tea
arugula is one of the cruciferous
vegetables
and so it has a lot of different
phytonutrients it's really good for your
liver because
it's really good for liver function and
if i have the option of getting arugula
i will always have a salad with arugula
way more than other types of salad
especially spinach because spinach is
high in oxalates which can lead to
kidney stones but arugula is low in
oxalates oxalates bind with calcium and
can form kidney stones and arugula has a
really great flavor it's kind of like a
peppery
sweet spicy
hot
flavor
and it doesn't need much to season it so
sometimes i'll just add the extra virgin
olive oil and maybe a little sea salt
and that's it arugula is really good for
inflammation it has
very high anti-inflammatory properties
arugula is also high in nitric oxide
which is good for libido and erectile
dysfunction and for cardiovascular
health because it supports the
endothelial walls that's the inner part
of the arteries and you can develop
clots in plaquing arugula is also high
in calcium
potassium
folate
magnesium vitamin c and k1 and lastly
arugula has some pretty potent
anti-cancer effects
all right the next food on the list is
salmon now of course i would always
recommend getting the wild caught salmon
and the type of salmon that is the
fattiest type of salmon i also like to
keep the skin on it because there's some
serious extra fat right beneath the skin
now if you're concerned about the
mercury levels the mercury levels in
salmon are substantially less than other
types of fish and they're way below the
danger threshold and the other thing you
need to know about salmon is it's high
in selenium selenium counters mercury if
there's selenium present you're not
going to be able to absorb mercury so if
you're going to eat salmon you don't
have to worry about mercury now out of
all the fish salmon is extremely
high in omega-3 fatty acids and omega-3
fatty acids are really good for the
brain the heart
your joints
omega-3 has anti-cancer properties
most people are consuming
way too many omega-6 fats as in soy oil
corn oil canola oil cotton seed oil and
they're very very low in omega-3 fatty
acids so they have this imbalance that
generates a lot of inflammation in their
bodies
so if you want to
systemically keep inflammation very low
you want to consume food high in omega-3
fatty acids and this is why i recommend
salmon at least a few times a week now
as far as the fat to protein ratio it'd
be like a one to two ideally you want
more fat to protein but because salmon
has these other health benefits i
included salmon on the list it's easy to
get it also tastes good so people will
consume it on a regular basis and you
can always add some additional fats to
salmon to spike it even more you know if
we look at omega-3 fatty acids and
compare salmon to something like cod
fish
if we look at just three ounces salmon
has over
thousand milligrams of omega-3 fatty
acids and cod has only 171 milligrams
let's see 2000 to
171 milligrams i think i'll go with the
salmon and salmon is high in potassium
zinc
and calcium all right the next one on
the list
is
cod liver now before you turn your nose
up to cod liver just hear me out you
know organ meats in general
are super super nutrient dense
the problem is the majority of the
population
do not like to consume them because they
don't taste very good and sometimes it's
hard to find high quality
organ meats because of all the toxicity
in the environment
you would never want to have
conventional
like beef liver or organ meats you want
them organic but wild caught cod liver
is not only easy to get it's very very
delicious it doesn't taste bad at all
it's not even fishy as long as you eat
it within one to two days don't make the
mistake of eating half of it and then
putting in the refrigerator and then
forgetting about it and then coming back
a week later
it'll be a little bit fishy but if you
eat it within one or two days it tastes
actually amazing it's actually delicious
the texture
is like pudding and it doesn't even to
me taste
fishy at all now you might consume it
and you might not even like the flavor
but
i think you should at least try it once
personally
i think consuming organ meats even beef
liver is a very good thing to do
i just
cannot seem to consume beef liver i just
don't like the taste but i will consume
cut liver all day long now the unique
thing about cod liver compared to beef
liver is that cod liver is much much
higher in omega-3 fatty acids in fact we
have some caliber right here if you can
see this right here icelandic
cod liver oil i think it's a little
blurry but this is wild caught okay
and it comes within its own oil so the
oil that they put in this is cod liver
oil and it's quite delicious now i do
not recommend consuming the whole thing
in one sitting it's a lot of fat and you
might not be able to digest it but one
half of these would be great so
maybe once a week i'll do half of this
um my first meal and then half in the
second meal now if you're on omad just
do half of this and one meal and the
other half the next day you can just
keep it in the fridge but like i said
before if you leave it in the fridge for
too many days
it might taste a little fishy now the
unique thing about cod liver oil
compared to fish oil in general is that
cob liver and cow oil
has
omega-3 fatty acids they have epa and
dha okay but fish oil does not have the
vitamin a and vitamin d that cod liver
and conditioner oil has
so cob liver and caliber oil have this
additional
extra benefit and vitamin a and i'm
talking about the active form of vitamin
a retinol is essential for your eye it's
essential for the immune system it's
essential for the inner lining of your
skin i'm talking about the sinuses the
esophagus the trachea your lungs and
it's really good for your kidneys well
and of course vitamin d as most people
know is awesome for blood pressure
pain
depression your immune system and
there's not many foods that are high in
vitamin d now cod liver also has vitamin
k2 it has iodine and it's loaded with b
vitamins and the cool thing about cotton
liver is it's fat to protein ratio it's
a five to one ratio so it has five times
as much fat to protein so on the insulin
index it's extremely low it will not
trigger insulin but the more fat to
protein as far as a ratio
the more ketosis you're going to be in
and if you don't actually like the cod
liver
at least do the cod liver oil
cod liver oil is one of the best things
that children should consume as well as
pregnant females because of the huge
benefits on the nutrients
as well as the essential fatty acids
omega-3 and one last thing where are you
going to find this you're probably not
going to find it in the grocery stores
just do a search online go to amazon do
a search and you'll find a lot of
different companies all right the next
one and some people will disagree on
this
hamburger okay hamburger just hear me
out i'm not talking about a hamburger
with a bun i'm not talking about
conventional beef i'm talking about
grass-fed organic hamburger okay
not lean
hamburger with like 90
that's too lean i don't recommend that
but why would hamburger be on the list
as a healthy food i'm also looking at
the practical aspects of food too it's
easy to get it's easy to digest you can
put in a lot of different foods and it
has some pretty good health benefits
now some people are going to say well
red meat is unhealthy and blah blah blah
well that is completely false i put a
link down below if you haven't seen my
video on red meat because if you're
eating high quality red meat it doesn't
cause cancer it's not going to cause a
heart problem
grass-fed organic red meat is not like
the processed meat or like you would eat
a hamburger at some fast food restaurant
it's completely different and some
people have a problem digesting red meat
but they usually don't have a problem
digesting hamburger and that is usually
because if you compare
most steak with hamburger hamburger has
more fat in fact hamburger compared to
steak is a two to one ratio it's twice
as fatty as its protein and that helps
keep the protein
in your small intestine
so the digestive juices and bile can act
on it and you'll get better digestion
if you're consuming leaner protein it
goes through the body faster and you
don't have as much time to fully break
it down
not to mention as we age we lose our
stomach acids and so the older you are
the less stomach acid you have to digest
red meat so a simple solution is just to
start taking betaine hydrochloride for
your stomach so you can increase the
acid and digest red meat
because a lot of elderly people are low
in iron they're anemic
and that's also because they don't have
enough acid in the stomach you need an
acidic stomach to absorb minerals
especially iron and calcium
and break down protein and kill
pathogens
so typically
hamburger is easy to digest i consume a
lot of hamburger on a regular basis on
the ketogenic plan hamburger is a really
good source of amino acids it's a really
good source of available iron compared
to like the iron and spinach the type of
iron you would get in red meat as well
as hamburger is so much
higher also hamburger is rich in b12
phosphorus
zinc
it's an excellent source of selenium b6
b2
b3 and b5
it's also high in something called
carnosine in fact beef is one of the
highest sources of carnosine and
carnosine reduces something called
glycation
glycation occurs naturally on our bodies
and promotes aging glycation is when you
have a sugar that attaches to a protein
or sugar that attaches to a fat and it
binds it up and it makes it unavailable
so it kind of clogs up the body and if
you're consuming carbs with sugar or
carbs with fat you're going to have a
lot of glycation so carnosine inhibits
glycation decreases inflammation
and carnosine also helps your immune
system now hamburger also has a lot of
creatine and creatine improves exercise
performance
exercise endurance
and can promote muscle growth and muscle
mass now there are other meats that are
higher in fat like duck and lamb but
even pork but i picked hamburger as
something on the list that's very
practical easy to get tastes good and
has a lot of health benefits all right
the next one on the list is pecans now i
wanted to pick foods in different
categories since a lot of people consume
nuts i wanted to talk about
the healthiest nut of all the nuts
and the reason why now out of all the
nuts pecans have the lowest net carbs
and as you can see
from the pecans right here and i love to
just take like a handful of pecans right
after a meal
and it gives me a good amount of fat and
it's very satisfying after a meal now
the carbs in pecans per cup is 14 grams
and it has a good amount of fiber like
10 grams
so that gives us a net carb of only 4
grams for an entire cup now remember
you're allowed up to 50 grams of carbs
if you're on keto
so four grams are insignificant
and the fat content is pretty high it's
like 71 grams now there are other nuts
that have higher amounts of fat like
macadamia nuts and pistachios the pecans
have the lowest net carbs and pecans
have a very good ratio of fat to protein
it's like seven fat to one protein so
that's going to be very low on the
insulin index pecans are very rich in
zinc and copper zinc and copper always
balance each other out so anytime you
have a food that has both zinc and
copper that's a good thing but pecans
are also loaded in vitamin b1 so if you
have stress you want to definitely have
pecans as part of your diet now pecans
out of all the nuts are very low in
oxalates again oxalates can bind with
calcium to form kidney stones and pecans
are really good for the heart they're
good for your blood sugars and out of
all the nuts pecans have the highest
amounts of antioxidants which can
decrease the complications from chronic
disease like diabetes heart disease and
inflammatory conditions and consuming
pecans are very easy
to digest
they're easier to digest than walnuts
peanuts brazil nuts and even macadamia
nuts and i like pecans because of the
taste as well because you can add them
in different recipes for keto desserts
and i put some down below if you want to
check them out all right the last one on
the list is extra virgin olive oil you
want to make sure you have the real
stuff as you can see i use the real
stuff right through here there's a lot
of different types that you can use i
don't you can read that
but you can see i use this olive oil i
use a lot of it on a regular basis
olive oil is interesting because if you
buy the cheap stuff at different
grocery stores you'll be lucky if you
get the real stuff because there's so
many
types of fake olive oil out there that
they blend other oils and it's just not
the same the real stuff has a little
bite to it
it has a great aroma like fresh cut
grass it's peppery and it gives you a
little tiny irritation in the back part
of your throat that's one indication to
know that it's the real stuff but i put
it on my salad on a daily basis so
what's so healthy about this extra
virgin olive oil well it does have
vitamins it has vitamin e it has vitamin
a
it has minerals like magnesium and
potassium now it is a fat so it's going
to have zero effect on your insulin
which is really good but it has
significant phytonutrients it has
phytonutrients that can extend your
aging you can live longer it supports
things like telomeres which if you have
shorter telomeres you're not going to
live as long
it supports and repairs mitochondria
and if you don't already know this
cancer is a disease of the mitochondria
and anything you can do
to protect
support and repair mitochondria will
give you anti-cancer
benefits now olive oil as far as an
anti-inflammatory
and something to help relieve pain
is equivalent if not comparable to the
effects of ibuprofen i'll put a study
down below so you can check that out and
compounds in extra virgin olive oil can
reduce beta amyloids
that's that stuff that develops as
plaquing in your brain when you have
alzheimer's so it's really good for the
brain and good for memory and focus and
concentration
it also has some really cool effects as
an anti-clotting
antimicrobial and retinol protective so
in other words it supports the retina of
the eye especially if someone has
diabetes or high sugars or high insulin
there are certain phytonutrients in
extra virgin olive oil that are 20 times
more powerful than green tea so don't
use it sparingly dump it on your salad
and the fat in the olive oil will help
you extract a lot of the phytonutrients
in the salad all right there you have it
the seven
healthiest foods now that you know what
to eat let's talk about what to avoid
with this video right here check it out